que monsieur girard jean g 77 ans j'ai
été appelé en juillet 1958 j'ai reçu mon
ordre de mission pour partir en algérie
on a été vite mis à la réalité
une fois qu'on était à alger on appris
la micheline pour nous rapatrier à tizi
ouzou et puis en cours de route on s'est
attaqué donc distribution des armes et
tous les plats ça peut être partout on
sait bien c'est puis de la rigolade
c'est plus si jolie que c'était on
partait pas en vacances oui c'est vrai
je me suis marié
donc j'ai eu une permission
exceptionnelle et on s'est marié à ville
d'avray en avril 1960
on était pressé de se marier on était et
puis le coin était quand même beau je
voulais y faire un peu découvrir et lui
montrer la vie comment la vie était là
bas c'est ça la boxe je garde surtout de
deux formidables qui avait cédé ce prix
de camaraderie
le matin les gradés ont salué pas on
serrait la main
est ce qu'on parle pas souvent non plus
c'était le service santé il y avait les
chirurgiens les médecins les infirmières
ont fait un travail remarquable mais ça
ça j'en suis toujours gardé un énorme
souvenir c'est et c'est pareil ça a été
bonne expérience mais c'est et certaines
fois très très talus réveillons nous
mais nous plaignons pas on est revenu
j'en ai 30 milles qui sont devant lui
vous savez j'ai pas trop changer la vie
on est partis d'amour quand on voit le
résultat maintenant ça pas donné grand
chose qu'est ce qu'on a ramené à rien on
a fait un travail de mémoire depuis onze
ans ça fera à 11 ans cette année dans
les écoles est vraiment les gamins nous
ont posé toute attente question mais
tout et on leur dit toujours à chaque
fois la paix ne vous battez pas avant la
cour de récréation ne vous bagarrer pas
parler discuter expliquer vous mais ne
fait pas la guerre